brandon sp says do you think philosophy
should be more crucially
in stem that's interesting
see the people of this channel sorry
that is
you who are watching you're likely
extremely high in openness extremely
high
otherwise you wouldn't be on this
channel and people who are high in
openness and high
in intellect tend to think that everyone
else should operate in the same way that
they do
and i don't think so i don't think that
everyone should be guided by philosophy
i don't think it interests them i don't
think that it's useful for them at all
and i i despise when
you'll hear me never or seldom i don't
like to use the word
never you'll hear me almost never say
the word
stupid to describe people of low iq
and that's because i don't
i don't think there's anything wrong
with people with low iq and i
i see it as a an arrogance of people who
are intellectual
to look down at people who are less
intellectual than them
at the same time they need them to run
their companies so they despise them yet
they need them
which means you you don't like the
people that you cooperate with which
means you don't like
humanity in some respect also iq is
heavily hereditary
that means that calling someone stupid
which to me is an ethically thick
word which means that it comes with a
descriptive
a description and a connotation so the
description is you have a low iq but the
the connotation is that you're inferior
because of it it's almost like the n
word
there's the description you're a black
person but then there's the connotations
that you're inferior and i'm insulting
you
the word stupid is like that and i don't
like that word stupid i don't
i i wish that intellectuals wouldn't use
that word
because it firstly makes people with low
iq feel horrible about themselves and
they can't
necessarily help it because like i
mentioned
the research indicates that iq is
extremely inveterate
it's it's like your ethnicity it's
something you can't
change though you can harm it you can
reduce it
and so it's like being racist to me if
someone says you're stupid that's like
it's the same it should be considered to
be the same as being racist
anyway brandon to answer your question
about do i think philosophy should
feature more crucially in stem education
i don't think so necessarily because i
don't think it's for everyone
though i need to think more about that
question
you